let's get fired up and go out there and
get the w today and every day
it's not every day that a canadian kid
gets to go on ellen like that what was
your reaction when you found out they
wanted to see you and meet you oh i was
just so excited this is so awesome like
i'm going to like los angeles to give
that speech to ellen and when i was
giving the speech challenge i felt so
good for 19 seasons you have given you
all on this stage you danced on you
joked her you laughed her you cried her
and you gave her you had her crying and
the whole audience gave you a standing
ovation how did that feel it just meant
a lot because uh we worked really hard
on that speech
what's the best advice that you can give
to someone that wants to give good
motivational speeches well i'd love to
give the secret to you guys like you
gotta know that your speech will be the
best we've got to stay comfortable and
confident
and staying positive for et canada like
what would you have to say to us in
terms of a motivational speech or some
words of wisdom coach cap let's go
get to w
[Applause]